all right joining us now he's a father
of the young man we mentioned earlier
Horus Lorenzo Anderson he was murdered
in Seattle's chop zone autonomous zone
or summer free loved zone on June the
20th
Horus Lorenzo Anderson senior is with us
along with the family reppu is the
executive director of not this time
Andre Taylor is with us sir I speak for
everyone I know watching this program
tonight we are so sorry for the loss of
your son and I I don't know how one I'm
a father as a son that's 21 and a
daughter that's 18 right around the age
of your son and this happened and what
ten days ago and the city still didn't
do anything to protect its citizenry
your thoughts sir I think they should
have just been men that this is I mean
it's incredible you know my son's 19 you
know I mean they should have been did
something about this a long time ago and
I don't you know like I said I'm not
understand black lives matter and
everything was going on and everything
but that's not my movement right now my
movement just let him know that was my
son that's right you know I'm saying
horse he runs over Anderson was my son
that I don't know I'm not I'm not with
all this whatever's going on none of
that I don't know nothing about that I
don't even know about that all I know is
this is my son and I love him and I've
been having Manny it's been my son and
this is incredible and I don't know that
should have been gone a long time ago
yes turnabout after the fact that he was
never no one ever came and spoke tall
buddy ever I never talked to when I the
day after only way I've found out I seen
my son the night before he passed away
he was on the couch I seen him and he
was like he was about to go to sleep
I've seen him I laughed at him we
tickled a little bit he stayed with me
on a day you know cuz he stays with me
anyway
my god and we laughed and I said I'm
going to sleep I went to sleep and only
way I found out was just two of his
friends just two friends that just
happen to be up there and they came and
told me they weren't even from Seattle
now mind you I haven't heard the police
department they never came my son's
address his ID him personally you know
him as a person he still had somebody
shoulda came knocked at my door and
still to this day should have been like
coming to talk to me and let me know
about my son to this day I really I
don't know nothing I'm just still
sitting here I haven't heard nothing
from nobody ain't nobody tell you you
haven't heard from the mayor you haven't
heard from the mayor you haven't heard
from the governor
you didn't hear from anybody haven't
heard from the mayor I haven't heard
from the police department I just now
recently just because we went on TV they
reach out to me and let me know what
they're what they're doing now but my
son's been you know he's been deceased
now for what - two weeks somewhere in
there I don't you remember I'm just so
my days is like every day is like every
day it's the same day so it's like I'm
confused and I'm I'm you know but I
understand that you know whatever's
going on but even at the time even when
my son passed away when I went to the
hospital there was there was no
detectives there there was no there was
nobody there no media there there was
nothing he was nobody he was just like I
mean we was just there and we just sat
there and I said man why are we sitting
here there's nobody else here though
it's like they didn't care it didn't
matter I haven't heard from the mayor I
haven't heard from Police Department and
from nope no City and nobody nobody only
thing I heard from is what you guys is
here for me now that's it you know I
watched yes I saw this picture then I
looked for the video this is a picture
of you I'm holding up was in The Daily
wire and what I see in this picture you
know if we can pan in close if we can
understand what I saw this picture was a
fellow father with with the son around
the same age as my son and and about in
the same age as my daughter and then I
read the article and I read what you
said and you actually said
you're not sleeping you could see my
eyes have been crying I'm not I'm trying
not to cry on TV and then you you went
on and you explained how you could not
understand how they allowed this
lawlessness to go on now you're taking
it to an entirely new level nobody had
the decency to call you and I assume you
heard the mayor out there calling this
the Summer of Love and the media
reporting as a Festivus to him what a
big block party yeah Thursday right now
they still haven't called me right now
I've been on TV they still haven't calm
he hasn't
nobody hasn't called me in there having
reached out to be like my condolence
nothing I don't I don't understand I
just I never understood you know all I
know is now they're acting now this is
today this is three weeks later if I
would I think if I would've never even
came on TV that would still be going on
right now let me just say Hannity I
don't want to make this no kind of
political statement if you can say it we
could say anything you want sir sir you
can say anything you want a nice show
yes you can decide to me I don't care I
just want this to stop I don't need to
criticize you you were very gracious he
was very gracious and offering your
condolences if nobody else app yes you
offer chores and and and that's not a
political statement yes you compared his
situations to your own with your
daughters and that's a big that means
something and I appreciate you for that
but what I don't want to do is get into
who's this and who's the fault who that
because we don't really know chop I
believe should have been dismantled at
least a week before yes when the first
violence happened we should have looked
at it a little differently and and that
wasn't done because I understand
navigating in a time in our country that
for the George Floyd situation people
were a little bit hesitant on how to add
and not to be the one to feel like
they're trying to put down young
people's voices and so I understand that
as well I just want to let you know
personally beyond all the politics that
I appreciate how you reached out
- horse and you said how you understood
this condition I think that's real big
of you and I Pollock and I appreciate
that - yes
you know I appreciated - because that's
probably the only thing I've ever heard
from anybody that's haven't heard that
from anybody else you know and are the
eyes you know heartbreaking on TV and
I've never been on TV so I don't know
how to be on TV but my son was a child
of special needs he was born at 25 weeks
you know so you know they compared him
they tried everyone and pretty and just
do that but you know he was a child you
know developmental delays you know I'm
saying so he's easily to manipulate you
know you can tell him some come on here
come on you know he's one of those
chronic type of child you know it's not
a very influenced by yeah it easily
easily influenced you understand easily
he was sitting on my couch I went to bed
I see my son when I went when I left
that night I'd seen him I came home I
seen him I was just I mean I seen him
and I just said I love you man I'm going
to sleep and you know that everything
else it just seems like a blur yeah I
don't even I'm dumb I'm still numb today
I got to bury my son tomorrow you know
and it's just been a lot going on and my
whole thing and my whole life is man
this is incredible and I'm like you
knows I still just day I just spend
almost two weeks I haven't heard from
nobody has nobody called they still
ain't ain't nobody called me or try to
find me and his ideas my ID so this
number is my number so thinking it's
easy to comforted detectives say hey
excuse me knocking my door excuse me let
me tell you what happened about your son
or let me I don't know nothing I had to
find it my son they wouldn't even let me
see my son that night they took me a
whole week before I can see my son and
they let me just say this Anderson Irama
right now Anderson yes you didn't you
weren't allowed to see your son for a
week please I wouldn't let him I went to
the hospital and they said they did we
couldn't see him they just said we can
see him there was now my my you know
when I go there I'm going there I'm
looking for a detective
somebody tell me something something but
when I get there there's nobody I mean
the hospital is blank there's it's it's
silence I'm gonna like what's going on
it you know so I go actually lady and
she tells me hold on so I wait day I
couldn't go in so I'm waiting for a long
time and I finally she tells me come in
and then she the doctor come tells me
all the only thing he tells me is my
son's decease I'm like well can I see
him
is it my son cuz you got to realize you
know at this time I'm going like is it
really my son you know I want to know is
it my son you know cuz this could be
somebody else's child you know but you
know you know I'm in my head I'm going
like years mine cuz everybody's saying
this but in my heart I'm going like you
know I just leave I got I need to see
him for you know I need to see him one
time just so just a baby so I can see
him I couldn't see him that day it took
that was Saturday it took all the way to
what Thursday I just seen him just last
week just Thursday and they they have to
whatever they did to him and make him so
they presentable whatever it was but I
need to you know I got to finally see
him and I and then my you know in my
heart I I knew it was it was my son now
this was my son because you know I
wouldn't want nobody else's son in and
this is incredible these kids and the
kids that passed whatever would happen
the other day you know all this on this
child man this is incredible
these are kids man I'm 50 years old man
is it these are kids man they should
have been stopped this a long time ago
that is starting to get it excuse me but
it is getting to a point you know where
you know it's I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
mr. Anderson I you know I can only say
this as a dad I you want to break Sean
Hannity no I'm a pretty tough guy that
will break me well you asked for this
and they need to come talk to me and
somebody to come tell me something cuz I
still don't know nothing and somebody
need to come to my house and knock on my
door
tell me something but you know I don't
know nothing
all that knows my son was he got killed
up there and he's just that is just a 19
year old
no that's or as Lorenzo Anderson that's
my son everybody I can tell you sir and
and Andre I didn't want to cut you off
earlier but you know on this show we've
done something we have every weekend
hundreds of kids shot people shot in
Chicago killed every weekend we get a
death toll nobody knows their names
these are American kids grandmothers
grandfathers moms and dads
we're the United States of America we
can fix this we don't fix this and you
do it by bright policing training police
you non-lethal weapons you do it with a
police presence not demonizing everyone
agreed what happened to George Floyd
can't ever happen again nobody it was
not a political issue how do we how do
we function as a society protected I and
I feel for his family to no disrespect
of course you do it comes with my son I
feel like it's personal just like you
saying that some somebody should help my
son he needed help he needed paramedics
he needed he needed the police to come
in somebody man you somebody was
supposed to go in there and help my son
you know can I tell you something sir
just anybody helping him they shouldn't
came in and help my son and even after
that steal I needed man let me know I
shouldn't know from some little kids I
said they have some I'm 50 years old
somebody the police somebody should've
knocked on my door
yeah said man we need to sit down and
talk to you and let us know what's going
on cuz I still don't know what's going
on I'm just I'm hearing from YouTube and
I don't I don't know nothing I don't
know nothing
all I know is my son's dead and I don't
know nothing and I'm still trying to
figure out answers so I can sleep I
don't sleep you know my kids don't sleep
I can't even stay
home they don't my kids don't there did
they feel like they're unsafe at home
now
so I I've been buying motel rooms in I
don't have that type of money for this
I'm not you know I wouldn't prepare for
this you know I'm saying so I just you
know I'm blessed at my son you know he's
going he's you know my auntie he blessed
she blessed me and his mom we all came
together and we got through it you know
it's a barium but other than that I
don't have answers you know I'm saying
this is my son somebody to come talk to
me man they're not talking to me man and
and I understand that black lives matter
but that's not what was going on here
you know I didn't see that that but I
was like yeah yeah he's somebody
yeah he's somebody and I mean I'm his
dad and I need answers and I demanded I
I refused nothing man
I will not lay down I I'm hurt but you
know I'm trying I'm just trying whatever
I'm trying to pull myself together and I
apologize for crying you know cuz you
know I just you know I don't know how to
you know I'm trying to pull myself
together I'm not really this TV is her
thing but Sir you you have niklas
somebody need to come somebody and
answer this somebody somebody tell me
something yes sir
Andre you know yes mr. Taylor you wanted
to say no I was asking did you say
something you said you wanted to play
something or something you know well
first of all I am all of the violence in
all of these cities I've been scrolling
names of the people don't hear of in
Chicago you know 4,000 from 2009 to 2016
4 thousand almost 4,000 dead thousands
and thousands more shot they just like
her statistics I scroll the name
sometimes like I'm doing it right now
and then I watched this video mr.
Anderson of you the night that your son
was shot they didn't I can't believe
they didn't tell you I can't believe
nobody's called you I'm never one by
that I can't watch and you have you have
a funeral tomorrow for your son yes
I mean you know if I could do anything
for you and your family I will do
whatever you need I will donate any
amount of money you need for all of this
is just outrageous to me my thing is I
will be gladly good and just I
appreciate all donations you know I'm
saying but I'm my thing it isn't about
the money
I know you lost your son I got I wake up
in the morning I look for my son in the
morning he's not there no more no sin
it's like I go in here I'm kissing a
picture you know so he's not there I
understand I'm it ain't even about the
money it's just like man somebody
somebody man something needs to happen
up something if it's changed in well
let's change something let's figure out
to change this play the tape let's don't
wait til tomorrow or the next day yes
yes this is this is the night that your
son was shot the police had to beg the
paramedics had to beg no somebody shot
somebody has a heart attack or stroke
seconds matter to save lives
they had to actually beg right to get
into the summer of love zone that the
mayor out there calls it to offer and
provide assistance I want your reaction
to this
they had to beg to go in as police and
medics to offer aid to somebody who shot
that turns out in the end to be your
child and by the way you never have to
apologize every single parent watching
this show right now I promise you they
identify I don't know the pain but I
know if you want to break me you hurt
your kids and you have nothing to
apologize just Thank You Sean
yeah let me just say this that that that
video you played is very ever seen in
any way no me neither but I'm saying the
fact that you're hearing officers
pleading with people at the chop area
which is why Horace spoke to that the
first time he did any media at all and
said that his beliefs were as mines were
that that place needed to come to an end
and chop had an incredible opportunity
to do something really great and to see
how it ended with violence and two
people being killed there a 16 year old
14 year old 14 year old five years life
right now it's really like that's the
really saddest story about what happened
with chop and I'm hoping that we all
could learn from what has happened here
I think our country still has an
incredible opportunity to do something
real real big at this time with policing
with bringing all of our people together
as we have done in Washington State and
being the first and only state with a
police accountability law I think we
still have an incredible opportunity to
unify in some capacity and this hope
that George Floyd's death will be that
unifying factor and that's what I'm
hoping for
for all Americans across the board
whether we be Republicans and Democrats
I'm not really concerned about that I'm
really addressing the American spirit
and things that we have overcome as a
country be Koch before and things that
we will likely overcome as long as we
unification again I do believe we are
the greatest country that have ever
existed and I like them I would like to
make sure that we're continuing to show
that by the work and not by our words at
it what both of you are saying tonight
is beyond powerful I happen to be a
Christian I'm a better Christian I know
all my faults and failures in life and
you know Christians I could say they
want to be forgiven kind of as a
misnomer among other people but if you
believe that and you believe we're all
children of God and I believe that too
and yet we are on a very fundamental
level we if we don't create safety and
security and we don't give kids a proper
education I mean we spent more the third
highest per capita spending city in
America is Baltimore for kids in school
and they have 13 high schools and not
one kid not one is proficient in math
and then I look at the violence every
weekend in Chicago and then I look at
what's happening in New York City
tonight as we speak and then I look at
what happened to your precious son mr.
Anderson and I'm listening to what
Aundre saying mr. Taylor say very
closely and we can we can protect people
New York City show showed us how to go
from 2,500 murders a year to 500 that's
500 too many but there are things that
we can do to make this a safer country
and I don't think all cops are bad I
actually believe 99% are good and you
get that one bad cop like it I got a
friend I got a friend that's a police
officer you know a friend one of my
friends the police I was right here in
Seattle police he works for Seattle
Police Department you know he's a good
friend of mine you know played
basketball with me everything he knows
me when he seen my face he he's gonna
recognize me when I see him you know but
I know he's doing his job so this
doesn't have to do with just Pacific's
is just have to do it my son needed help
and I don't feel like they helped my son
didn't nobody help my son and nobody
still they haven't reached out to you
know I feel like he doesn't if without
this he would just be nobody just
doesn't matter just another guy just
another child just swept up on the rug
and that's it and forgotten about so
John can I say something I know this is
your show but I recognize something that
maybe I haven't given you credit for
before I don't know because I don't like
being in politics on no half whether
it's Republican or Democrats
grandma Kratts but let me just say
something I've seen you before
you were very popular figure I've seen
that I've seen you on your show take
command of your own show you have a
right to do that but to be as gracious
as you have been today makes me feel
like you are being a better Christian
makes me feel like you know it gives me
a different type of Hope just to really
showcase what's inside of you and what I
want to believe this inside of you you
know I again I don't want to just say
things just to be saying it but I often
want to give credit where credit is due
no matter on what side and data is on
and I just wanna thank you for that I
don't ever want to have to interview
another mr. Anderson or you again on
this issue this is not politics to me if
we forget let's just look at the
fundamentals public put R and D
liberal-conservative aside how about we
protect America's treasure horn Horace
Lorenzo Anderson jr. is Knight was 19
years old and he's America's treasure
and we didn't protect him yargh we
didn't even offer a maid and then you
got a double whammy nobody even called
you I'm stunned I just I I just I use
our future with our kids there's no
future without the keys right here
there's no future you're right when and
I mean somebody's kids did this to my
son
I still even I look at that camera I
wouldn't wish this on you and nobody
else's kids man this is incredible you
know and I'm being a Christian now I'm
doing my heart that's what I'm trying to
be I'm
being more Christian than my heart and
be like Lord just bless me and so I can
be strong with my family with my kids
you know but you know whoever's looking
at this camera they see me and they see
my face if your kids involved you know
you figure that out you know you take
them in you do that you know but that's
not that's in God's hands now everything
is in God's hands now and God's gonna
take care of it I feel like that's what
God's gonna take care of me and he's
gonna take care of my son
and everything has been good and I just
want to be just be laying my son you
know to rest nicely and I give me some
rest you know and lay down and just be
like you know I just try to figure
everything else late you know maybe
either happen later on maybe I get
answers later on you know but right now
all my questions there's no answers
that's where I'm at right now you know
you said something tonight that as a dad
again I'm I take really it hits me it
hurt hit me deeply is that you kiss a
picture you don't get to hug your son
ever again you don't get to hold them
and tell them you love them ever again
and nothing I mean I don't I don't know
how yeah I don't I don't have advice how
to end it for anybody to get over that
and I guess my question is nobody yeah I
can't I can't just tell him I love him
you know one thing about me though I had
I raised all my kids one household all
my kids I I had that I had the privilege
to be able to raise all my kids you know
so they've been with me so I'm like they
still with the rest of my kids they
still stay with me and I got a chance to
raise him guy gave my son to me at two
years old and I've been raising since
two years old the best I can you know
and you know he said you know kids they
do what they do
my thing in life was I can't teach I
thought all I can do is teach you how to
live I can't I couldn't teach him how to
die cuz I ain't never died before so I
don't know how to teach my kids out of
die all I can teach you is I I'd rather
teach how to live so when you say that I
respect that because when I wake up in
the morning
I'd be trying to walk in the room I want
to see him like man all I got as a
picture now and I'm going and I love you
and I'm just hoping you know cuz I've
never been there before so I can't tell
you you know he's dead he can hear you
know we say this and we believe in
things because that's what we supposed
to believe in God we believe in
everything but I've never been dead so
I'm hoping that he hears me because even
before he passed away
one thing I always tell everybody I tell
my kids every day I love you I kiss them
they're old they said that David met you
know I didn't you know our dads your
kids I mean I kiss you their dad quit
kissing on me it don't matter I love you
because that's my love that shared
because that's one thing I can say he
knows that I loved him you know I'm sad
because I always and he got a sister he
got many got family behind and that
really loved him that man they really
loved this man he was a he was the
blessing man it was just incredible he
was a incredible blessing and everybody
loved him and that was my son and I
can't tell her no more but if he can
hear me now you know I love you son you
know with all my heart you know I'd talk
to him in the morning and showers I tell
him man I just wish that she would've
just stayed home that night um you know
if you know you were wise stuff you know
I can't rewind this is something that I
never thought you know I seen I've seen
Jordan you know Floyd I seen all these
other kids and I said that's terrible
you know that's terrible you know even
what happened just recently you know
that's terrible when you look at stuff
you you never think that it would it
would be you one day you know the camera
look at you you now the cameras looking
at me like this this is unbelievable
like this is me because you know I I
tell my kids I love him I I raised him
right
I been playing football since he was six
I I coached football changed my life
around you know my life just you know I
made man I don't do nothing all I do is
then I cook home-cooked meals for my
kids every night and and we we were you
know I've been knowing him since we were
younger younger
I mean we're ain't we ain't Saints yeah
I ain't no I mean I mean I come from a
checkered past he comes from a checkered
past but we changed our life
yeah for myself or the girl all my kids
that you know life's different I'm
changed our life and to encourage other
youngsters that might be in the same
situation that we were in that you don't
have to be defined by your mistakes or
by your past
I said I mentor other kids I did I've
been a mentor in other schools um and I
coached football for eight years I you
know this is what I got I work with the
community anyway within my community I
don't go to many communities because I
don't go that far but but they're my
community always worked with the kids
and just be like because they know who I
am so see this kind of get kind of hard
I'm like well you know what that what
about me is like what like everybody
forget about you like man like you know
it's just life is just incredible your
noises and what do you think what do you
let what are your last thought sanity
you know I'll tell you what my thoughts
are mr. Taylor
I just heard mr. Anderson describe what
I think is the most well none of us are
perfect we're all sinners all have
sinned and fallen short I believe that
I'm guilty and when I hear when you
talked about mr. Anderson that you you
hug and you kiss your older children and
you coached your your son and you
brought them up right you're not perfect
but you did everything you could and you
hug them and you kiss them and you let
them know you love them every day I hope
that my kids feel the way I feel about
you as a father because you sound like
an amazing amazing father to me and
that's what that just what makes this
that much harder you know you can't kiss
a picture you're right what you said it
hurts and I honestly the worst part is
is the the that I do believe in an
afterlife I really do but the time
between now and then yeah you won't see
your son and it just doesn't have to
happen we can do better than this
I know some people would turn this into
a gun debate or this no just just simply
every city needs to create a zone we'll
call it a safe and secure zone so that
every child
could have a childhood and have coaching
and have parents that hug them and love
them and don't have to worry about
drive-by shootings and worry about gangs
and worry about drug dealers and worry
about all these other things that we
should all as Americans agree on and I
think with the amount of money we spend
on education more than any other country
in the industrialized world we can
create a ladder so every child could
pursue happiness you know the Latin
phrase for education is dukkha day to
bring forth from within
well that means God put it there and we
just got to bring it out of every every
son and daughter we have and your you
know these are our treasured America's
treasure and you were describing I think
yeah the the the perfect parent that
loves to kiss and love on his children
and be there for his children that's
what I hear and honestly I tip my hat to
you and the fact that that that you can
share all of that it is beyond powerful
to me you know I you're right mr. Taylor
I talk a lot about politics and I
believe it with all my heart but if our
politicians can't agree on one thing and
can't fix one thing and that's safety
and security they have failed in their
job and if I don't care what party
you're in if you don't support safety
and security and a good education for
our children get out of the way because
America can do better than that I mean I
said we add one to that let me add one
let me add one to that safety security
and accountability a man will run hand
in hand we can't have one without the
other and family yeah because that's a
that's right based on the world I don't
care if you don't have family it's you
have nothing because all based on family
I live off my whole life is based on I'm
50 years old so my whole thing is my
kids family I just wanted you know it's
family things you know so when they're
in when it's all said it's family you're
saying it doesn't come with politics
that don't come with nothing just come
with you
you I'm saying is real so when this
family is his that's family and that's
that's it you know family when you say
family maybe that's it
that's your heart you know and that's my
family that's my son and I'm gonna love
him forever you know we're gonna love
you forever like you say we can't talk
to him but I still talk to him you know
I still I do my own talking you know
every week we have our own conversation
that's yeah I'm always cuz that's in my
heart but I just want the world to know
that that was my son and I understand
Floyd everything I'm with black lives
matters I'm with all that that's cool I
appreciate that
but it's just certain things that should
matter outside that then we got to put a
stamp on and say hey hey certain things
these our children know to remember he's
chosen a guy you know say man these are
baby
hey man I'm saying so you're taking away
you're taking away generations you're
taking away our youth you're taking away
my son never had a chance to have
another child so my grandbaby would
never be invested this is what I'm posed
to be fruitful and multiply and make my
family so we multiplied so we have
family you don't sin so that's what
that's the generation took it out from
me right now my son is not able to do
that you know I'm saying so man kids I
look at the kids I'd say this and I tell
you right now look on the listen to your
parents man this to your dad I know you
get mad sometime and you be like and dad
don't man that you marry and you'd be
rebellion you'd be like no no stop they
even though they did they tell you just
because they love you did they love you
if they your friends if they love you
they tell you some your friends don't
agree with you all the time a good
friend never agree with you because he
knows when you're wrong said no you're
wrong now you know if you're wrong I'm
wrong you know so as kids we got it you
know I understand kids you'd be like
this your parents are the number one
thing in your life never ever ever go
around that and talk to your parents
first
your mom and dad knows everything before
anything you know I'm saying if you feel
like mommy right we'll go to dead
somebody they got a dig at to theirs if
that
appearance is is that is their their
responsibility to show you as a parent
how to be it you know how about it so
you can grow up and live you know I'm
saying other than that it's impossible
to live if you don't have family you
need family you know you need it Annie
thank you for having us on your show you
were gracious to us you were kind you
say - yeah you know that you say this
because I know I I know I speak for I
would say the overwhelming 99% of
American people in this you know we
can't bring back your son I've been
doing radio 31 years TV 25 years and I
think that the message that both of you
have conveyed tonight is probably more
powerful than every show I've done
combined and I hope that so-called
leaders and elected officials listen
because every mom and dad hears you I
hear you and you're in my prayers if I
can ever do anything I want to stay in
touch with you and and continue this
discussion off air thank you for sharing
your time we pray for you you and your
family and so sad about your loss thank
you so much both of you for being with
us for this all this time god bless
america very much thank you listen
everybody god bless you god bless you
too sir